I removed the core combo from my bracket 4 pirate
deck, along with some of the supporting cards
for it, replacing them with some more generalist
cards along with a couple bizarre finishers. Well,
it wasn’t exactly a replacement. The original deck
is still fully playable, but I made a 10-card swap
out package that could be implemented to move the
deck down from a cutthroat high power combo deck
that usually wins on turn 5 to a grindier pirate
midrange deck that usually wins on more like turn
8-10. On the surface that sounds fine, great
even—I have a deck whose core I like, and I get
to split it into a high-powered bracket 4 style
version and a more mid-powered bracket 3 style
version. However, the resulting theoretically
mid-power deck feels very strange to play, and
I think it points to some odd truths about what it
means for a deck to be a particular power level.
Something that might have already caught
your attention is that 10-card number—a
firmly bracket 4 deck is really just 10 cards
from being a totally fair bracket 3 deck?
And this wasn’t swapping 10 good cards for 10 bad
cards either—this is more like swapping 1 insanely
good card and 9 highly specific support
cards for 10 generally decent cards. So,
how does that work? Well, to get into that,
I need to start by covering what the original
deck does. This deck was intended to be the most
powerful possible pirates deck I could make on a
$100 budget, and it does so by leveraging
its command zone extremely aggressively.
Francisco is a two mana flying pirate that
filters whenever one or more of my pirates
hit an opponent, and Malcolm is a three mana
flying pirate that makes a treasure whenever
one or more of my pirates hit an opponent, so the
core of this deck ended up being these two paired
with a one mana pirate to get the deck set up
with a powerful early engine. This engine builds
into a combo turn with Time Sieve, a two mana
artifact that can sacrifice five artifacts to
grant an extra turn. Malcolm creates 3 artifacts
per turn as long as I’m hitting three players,
so all that’s required to keep taking turns with
Time Sieve is a card like Academy Manufactor,
Irenicus’s Vile Duplication, or Storm Fleet
Negotiator that can close that gap with some
extra artifacts per turn. Paired with
a bunch of tutors and draw engines to
find the various pieces—and an eye watering
13 counterspells to keep my plans safe with
spare treasures—this deck can pretty reliably
yield well-protected combo wins on turn 5-6.
So this is a pretty strong deck, but it’s also
not one I’ve ended up playing with a whole lot.
I love playing a highly interactive deck with lots
of evasive creatures and coastal piracy effects,
but this deck was that plus a fast combo win,
so it just doesn’t feel right in most games.
And fundamentally this is why I was interested in
creating a pivot for this deck—to let my pirate
guys see more games. The budget of this deck
also might make it more clear why I thought
10 cards would be a fine number to swap out—the
card quality here just isn’t that high. There are
no game-changers in this original deck, and not
a whole lot of what you might consider staples.
If we look at the 13 counterspells in particular,
there are a lot of weird ones you might not have
heard of: Spell Snare, Lookout’s Dispersal,
Memory Lapse. I also run every one-mana pirate
in the game, including the vanilla heavy hitter
Grasping Scoundrel and the Foglio classic that
is Cloud Pirates. So surely, I figured, this would
be an easy power-down. My deck is full of dogshit,
so I’ll just cut the Time Sieve, some tutors, and
some of the hyper-low-cost interaction spells. In
their place will come in a few pieces of creature
removal, a few value engines, another land,
and a few much goofier wincons. One of these
wincons is Vorpal Sword, an equipment that can
turn an evasive creature and eleven total mana
into a dead opponent in short order. The other
two are the commander storm cards Skull Storm and
Echo Storm, which help mitigate the weakness of
this deck getting its commanders shut down a lot.
All three of these are pieces of tech that I tried
out in the high-power version of the deck, but
which just didn’t really make sense in terms of
power level, and it’s satisfying to be able to
still let them live in a version of the deck.
So here was the deck, now split into two.
I double-sleeved the whole deck in Dragon
Shield outer sleeves, and then color-coded the
two 10 card swap packages with ordinary colored
sleeves. If you want to attempt something similar
with these outer sleeves, follow my affiliate link
in the description and use code “salubrious” at
checkout. That aside, how did this new version
of the deck feel? Was it indeed a mid-power
deck? Well, I can’t say the answer to that
is no. It has won a pretty unremarkable number
of games, and it threatens wins on a timeline
that’s pretty normal for a bracket 3 deck—usually
around turn 8-9. The overall plan for the deck is
evasive creature beatdown, with a lot of effects
that generate value when combat damage is dealt,
and the deck’s more dedicated wincons
dovetail naturally from this commander-centric
light-pirate-beats plan. However, there is still a
distinctly weird character to this deck, and that
comes from how precision-built it is to be strong
early in the game, and how much protection it has
for its gameplan. If it does indeed land turn 1
pirate, turn 2 Francisco, turn 3 Malcolm, or an
equivalently strong rollout, it starts building up
resources really fast. Three treasures a turn is
pretty standard, and with one of the seven Coastal
Piracy effects in this version of the deck,
it will also often be drawing three cards a turn
starting on turn 4, with that number often scaling
up quite a bit within a couple turns. The deck
does exactly what you would want a deck to do
as it’s gearing up for a crushing turn five or
six win, because that’s what the core of this
deck was designed to do, but in this version
that crushing win never quite materializes.
The deck just keeps drawing cards and making
treasures and playing pirates until either it
finds one of its finishers, wins through critical
mass, or loses its footing and falls behind.
This effect is amplified by this deck’s
interaction suite. The original deck
had 13 counterspells and a pirate that
can be sacrificed to protect something,
as well as seven removal spells. This new version
effectively trades three one mana counterspells
for a set of creature removal tools that cost
3, 4, and 9 mana respectively. In terms of
this deck’s ability to slow opponents, this feels
pretty fine—17 of the deck’s 20 interactive tools
are single-target in nature, and half of the
deck’s counterspells can’t even hit creatures.
This deck can draw a lot of cards and create a
decent number of treasures, but it’s just not
capable of keeping the whole table suppressed
for any significant length of time. However,
I’ve had several games where this deck did seem
to give off “controlling pubstomper” energy,
and that fact fundamentally comes down to the
protection suite here. This deck is carefully
engineered to be as good at protecting its board
as possible, right from the first Malcolm trigger
on turn 3. In the original version there were
14 protective tools, and here that number
drops to 11, but in a deck with plentiful draw and
filtering that still ends up feeling plenty large.
And, this feature intersects with the deck’s early
power spike in some really interesting ways. If on
turn 4 I have three pirates, am creating three
treasures per turn, and am drawing three or
more cards per turn, that generally makes me the
early big bad of a bracket 3 commander game. Then,
when the removal inevitably starts flying,
I get to effortlessly brush it aside with my
plentiful treasure mana even if I tapped out, and
my draw engines will typically draw me into more
counterspells and additional draw engines, which
will in turn draw me into even more protection
for my commanders. In the most extreme games,
I’ve thrown out five or more counterspells to
protect my board in the first six turns of the
game, all while drawing piles upon piles of cards
through a wide board of pirates and multiple
coastal piracy effects. And just think about
how this looks for my opponents: I’m the deck
that’s drawing 8 cards per turn with my board of
many permanents and countering removal spell after
removal spell, seemingly executing an unstoppable
gameplan with cold precision. Every attempt
to slow me down falls short, every point of
resistance anticipated. I’d call this pubstomping,
but it’s more like pubstomp-simulator because I’m
not actually dealing a lot of damage or removing
a lot of opposing threats, I’m just doing all of
other things that a pubstomping player would do.
This is made all the worse because when this deck
does lose its foothold, it’s not usually
because my opponents got off a sick alpha
strike spell or landed a perfectly timed board
wipe—the first couple of those got countered.
Instead, the deck falls behind with a whimper,
taking damage and losing permanents here or
there until it’s forced to allow a board
wipe to resolve, or alternatively forced
to offer up its board as blocks in the face of an
overwhelming attack. It does succumb to pressure,
but it feels more like collapsing under its own
weight than getting set back by an opponent.
In a dedicated playgroup, I think basically
all of this deck’s weirdness would melt away
after playing against it a handful of times. If
you know the deck’s formula—early power spike,
glut of single target interaction, commander
storm cards to give a second wind after an
eventual fall-off—in that case, none of this
feels all that scary anymore. On the other hand,
the people at the LGS seeing this for the first
time, and maybe even meeting me for the first
time? They’re interpreting opposing decks through
the lens of the decks they’ve already played
against, and based on the idiocultures of the
Magic: the Gathering spaces they inhabit. And
this feature can go the opposite way as well.
Just as me drawing half a dozen cards per turn
doesn’t necessarily signal being unstoppably far
ahead in an early game centered deck like this,
seeing somebody doing entirely mundane things in
a late-game centered deck could easily be quite
problematic. In my Sharuum control deck, I’ve
noticed that if I’m not clearly behind on turn 5,
I’m actually ahead. If my life total is still
in the 30s, my hand is decently stocked,
and my board isn’t utterly dwarfed by that of my
opponents, I probably have at least a 40% chance
of winning the game, and that just comes down to
the deck being engineered to utterly dominate in
the late game. I do try to communicate this
power profile, because I want a fair game:
“Hey folks, this is my Sharuum control deck,
I sure hope I make it to the late game and get
to do awesome stuff with Astral Slide.” I’ll
likewise do a bit of that with the bracket 3
version of the pirates deck, communicating that
my two most powerful wincons are Vorpal Sword
and Haunted One, but with both of these
decks communication can only go so far,
and that comes down to yet another challenge
of commander with randos: the complexity.
With a playgroup you can get to know all of your
opponents’ decks in and out and have an intuitive
feel for when a deck is or isn’t having a good
game, but with fresh opponents and less familiar
decks that can be much more challenging. Even
if somebody tells you the rough profile of their
deck, that’s something you need to remember,
and their account might omit details or include
built-in assumptions that you don’t necessarily
share. So, people go based on what they can
see—life total, cards in hand, and especially
what’s on board. If I’m there with a wide board
of pirates resolving 12 combat damage triggers per
turn, it’s easy for the person quietly ramping or
tutoring or setting up synergy pieces to fall
into the background. Likewise, that background
person is me when I’m playing one of my greedier
decks. Fundamentally, the biggest thing this comes
down to is how telegraphed a deck is in what it’s
doing. A deck that’s beating the “I’m a problem”
drum starting on turn 4 with a flurry of activity
on board is going to be much more noticed,
and more easily kept under control, than a deck
whose resources are more subtle. A deck that wins
highly visibly on turn 6 could easily feel much
more fair to a table of strangers than a deck
who pulls a combo win out of nowhere on turn
7, even if it’s theoretically a stronger deck.
This all could sound like a “problem” of some
sort, but to me it’s ultimately more of an
interesting observation. Yes, tables with less
familiar players are going to be different than
tables with a playgroup, and those distinctions
are interesting to dive into, but in neither
place is this pubstomping-simulator pirates deck
truly a problem. It feels like it swims against
the social forces of playing commander with
strangers, but so does any deck that dares stray
from the most conventional molds of commander
decks. And even if my spidey senses feel like
they’re picking up on some social friction when
I’m hitting my strongest turns with this deck,
ultimately I don’t think most people are
walking away from playing against this
deck having their day made worse for it. They’re
just playing commander, just like anybody else.
Thanks for watching, and thanks to Archidekt for
supporting the channel. Archidekt’s maybeboard
categories give me an elegant way to do
something weird like this with a deck,
and if you want to take a look at this deck’s
list you can find that down in the description.
I’d also like to thank my supporters on YouTube
and Patreon, some of whom are on-screen now.
If you want to support me in making this sort
of content, as well as disappearing to Serbia
occasionally, you can join my patreon or
sign up for a YouTube membership today.